beinahe sechs monate krieg in der
ukraine und auch heute wollen wir uns
die militärische lage im land ansehen
und uns ansehen mit welchen waffen denn
beide seiten versuchen ihren vorteil zu
gewinnen zuerst zur militärischen lage
hier gehen die kämpfe im osten des
landes extrem weiter und zwar einmal
hier bei der stadtbach mut etwas östlich
von grammatik aber auch bei donetzk und
donuts das finde ich ganz interessant
dort gab es wir sehen uns auch dieses
dunkelrot hier dort gab es kaum kempf in
den letzten monaten das heißt dort hat
man gesagt gut da haben wir eine feste
front wir versuchen sonst überall wir
sehen das hellrot die hier im norden
aktiv im süden und so weiter vorzurücken
aber jetzt versuchen die russischen
streitkräfte auch von donetsk aus nach
westen vorzudringen einmal im süden der
stadt bei marica und im norden bei pesci
und afrika bisher ohne erfolg aber dort
gibt es eine neue offensive ja wir
machen die russen dass die machen das
mit neuaufnahmen sie erreicht mit
uralter artery das ist eine d20
artillerie die wird seit 1947 also seit
75 jahren an russland gebaut oder in der
sowjetunion damals natürlich gebaut und
wir sehen hier neue aufnahmen der
sogenannten volksrepublik donetzk die
diese geschützte wie sehen ihre 2 einen
zeh vorne eins hinten im wald versteckt
in stellung bringt und dann auch nutzt
russland hat also überhaupt gar kein
problem ist sogar seine 75 jahre fast
zweit weltkriegs technologie hier
einzusetzen und damit einen vorteil
gegen die ukrainischen truppen zu
erzielen und man muss es so klar sagen
auch wenn das uralte geschütze sind die
alleinige masse diese masse mit der
russland sicher rein bringt und damit
auch feuern kann gibt ihr dem land
bislang einen vorteil im osten gegen die
ukrainische armee wir gucken uns zum
thema panzer etwas an diese aufnahme
einer drohne haben uns erreicht aus der
von der grenze von aktiv und donetsk aus
der region das ist ein russischer sehr
moderner t90 panzer der seit den 90er
jahren etwa hergestellt wurde und wir
sehen aber dass der hier schon rauch von
einer artillerie getroffen wurde und nun
sehen wir eine mächtige explosion das
heißt dieser gesamte panzer und
wahrscheinlich auch seine besatzung löst
sich hier in rauch auf und wurde von der
ukrainischen armee sozusagen zerstört
wir sehen jetzt hier nochmal am rand von
einem wald stand ja das heißt diese
offensive dort geht auch weiter in der
region aktiv und donuts und diese wurde
von der ukrainischen armee hier
gestoppt was macht russland russland
braucht neue panzer russland braucht
unbedingt neue panzer an die front und
wir haben neue aufnahmen gesehen aus dem
westen russlands dass wir erinnern uns
so sieht ein bisschen aus wie im januar
ausland bei weg neue panzer an die front
aber der unterschied ist dass im extrem
alte t 80 panzer t 80 eigentlich ein
panzer der seit 1978 gebaut wurde in die
80er jahren gebaut wurde das besondere
an dem hier ist wir können das mal kurz
anhalten dass wir hier keine reaktiv
panzerung haben beispielsweise wir haben
keine überarbeitung wir haben kein
modernes feuer system sondern wir haben
diesen panzer noch genauso wie er aussah
1989 wo er wahrscheinlich eingemottet
und in ein lager gestellt wurde dass
also das besondere in anführungsstrichen
neue panzer die in die ukraine geschafft
werden aber eben einen stand der noch
sowjetische technologie und nicht
russischer technologie also nicht in den
neunzigern 2000 überarbeitet
entspricht das also zeigt vielleicht
auch so ein bisschen die verzweiflung
zeigt aber auch wie viel immer mehr
russland nachliefern kann und das ist
einfach nie auf oder offenbar dieser
nachschub sondern man hat die vollen
lager auch die ukraine hat viele viele
panzer verloren in den letzten in den
letzten monaten aber es auch hier kommen
neue an- und wieder ein anfangs zwischen
neue wir sehen hier können wir das ganze
mal festhalten eine armee wenn man so
möchte von panzern hier der erste mit
einer ukrainischen flagge wir sehen hier
12 34 panzer insgesamt zwölf panzer an
diesem konvoi die hier in person fahren
im süden des landes und dabei handelt es
nicht um t 72 m 1 panzer panzer die auf
den osteuropäischen oder
mitteleuropäischen ländern in den
letzten wochen gespendet wurden die
meisten davon über 200 aus polen aber
auch aus nord mazedonien aus bulgarien
aus anderen ländern kamen die aus
tschechien und wir sehen hier einen
relativ großen konvoi das also in
anführungsstrichen wieder neue panzer
die die ukraine bekommen hat die
immerhin überarbeitet wurden in den 90er
jahren und jetzt eben aus polnischen
bestände aus anderen mitteleuropäischen
ständen beständen der ukraine zur
verfügung gestellt wurde darauf also
baut auch die ukraine dass sie hier in
der region carson im süden wo sie seit
wochen eine gegenoffensive fahren will
aber die kommt noch nicht so richtig in
schwung wo sie ihm vordringen möchte und
dass jetzt auch mit panzern aus
sowjetischer produktion aber
europäischer überarbeitung tun
[Musik]